alright let's go back to our top story
and the number of jobless in the past
three weeks alone in the United States
climbing to almost 17 million we can
speak now to Robert Scott who's director
of trade and manufacturing policy
research at the Economic Policy
Institute he joins us on skype from
Washington mr. Scott welcome to the
program job losses on this level have we
seen anything like it in recent history
these this jump in unemployment is
unprecedented in the United States since
at least the second world war nothing
we've seen nothing like this no s 75
years so losses on this level this
quickly what effect will that have on
the US economy well this is different
from say for example the Great Recession
of ten years ago this was an intentional
shutdown of the domestic economy
estimates are that we could ultimately
lose between 20 and 30 million jobs or
more by the summer in the United States
and this is going to cause a collapse in
economic output again it could fall as
much as 15 to 20 percent unprecedented
in living memory of most people in this
country and that of course is going to
have negative ramifications for the rest
of the global economy as well I was
going to say all the nations of the
world have deep economic problems from
the coronavirus as it is but what effect
will it have having the the US economy
under this kind of pressure well the US
is the biggest buyer in the world we
import more goods than anyone else in
the global economy our imports are going
to collapse that's going to reduce
demand in the rest of the world so trade
is going to collapse
overall in addition this is going to
cause a decline in output the rest of
the world and in the United States we've
been able to respond with a massive two
trillion dollar relief package we're
already talking about the next trillion
dollar-plus relief package that can keep
income flowing in the u.s. there are
many
countries around the world do not have
the luxury of engaged in that kind of
deficit spending they don't have the
capacity to borrow at those levels added
to that this crisis is also going to
freeze up financial markets around the
world money is flowing into the US as a
safe haven and that's causing financial
crises in over a hundred countries
around the world they don't have that
access to capital that we do it's
incredibly savouring is now how far do
you think this could go and some people
are talking saying that we haven't even
got to the point which that the figures
are right at this point in time they're
gonna be more than that and in the end
we could reach 40 million jobless it
could go that deep in the United States
we're talking anywhere from from 15 to
30 percent of total employment or total
unemployment in the United States
already we've lost about 11 and a half
percent of jobs on top of existing
unemployment of about three and a half
so we're already approaching fifteen
percent unemployment in in the United
States but the question is how long is
the shutdown is going to persist and how
long is gonna take us to recover we've
made some of the worst choices in the
United States other countries have
chosen to employ what sometimes called
work-sharing or a government tastes the
companies for example in Great Britain
and Denmark they pay them to keep
employees on the payroll people keep
getting wages and they remain attached
to the firms that they work for the
United States has done a very poor job
of that instead tens of millions of
being thrown out of work and they're
losing their connections to their firms
and many of these firms themselves are
going to go out of business and so we
won't be able to restart the economy on
a dime as some are hoping right well
extraordinary figures in extraordinary
times Robert Scott we appreciate your
perspective thanks very much thank you
sorry